bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parlement hebdo va refaire toute
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
au 45 minutes avec quatre guides
derrière bonjour tout le monde et quelle
est cette semaine dans l'actualité la
visite éclair de françois hollande en
centrafrique où l'opération sogaris a
fait ses premiers morts l'intervention
est soutenu à droite comme à gauche mais
elle suscite des réserves et des
questions notamment sur le coût et la
durée de l'engagement français dans
l'actualité aussi les élections
municipales à trois mois du scrutin les
électeurs pensent eux d'abord à leur
feuille d'impôt la fiscalité locale
préoccupation numéro un des français
c'est ce qui ressort d'un sondage publié
cette semaine on le verra tout à l'heure
son nom est revenue toute la semaine
dans les médias nicolas sarkozy une
image dans le stade de soweto aux côtés
de françois hollande un sondage des
petites phrases dans la presse est un
documentaire sur les chaînes
parlementaires que vous nous
présenterons en deuxième partie
d'émission
est l'invité de parlement hebdo cette
semaine et christian jacob bonjour
bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur ce
plateau vous êtes président du groupe
ump à l'assemblée nationale député de la
4e circonscription de seine et marne et
maire de provins alors c'est la
tradition je vous propose d'abord
d'écouter ce que certains de vos
collègues à l'assemblée pense que vous
écoutez un gaulliste et chiraquien c'est
aussi un très bon président de groupe
qui sait qui s'est rassemblée et puis
c'est quelqu'un aussi qui est très
pugnace qui a des convictions et qui
sait les défendre c'est une personnalité
qui est assez entière je crois voilà
qu'est entière qui qui se projette dans
qui se projette dans combat politique
sans tricher j'aime bien excessif
parfois violents on le propose je parle
et plus incohérent fidèles parce qu'il
est fidèle à l'ancien président de la
république jacques chirac
combatif parce que à l'assemblée
nationale est un opposant farouche et
puis paysans parce que i les liens de la
terre et c'est pour moi une qualité
assembleur compétents et
c'est véritablement un homme sur qui on
peut compter
déterminée
obstiné
de droite
la réaction plutôt sympathique à votre
égard combatif obstiné entier vous vous
reconnaissez dans ce portrait express
oui il n'y a rien qui me qui me kyi qui
me choque c'est toujours difficile de
savoir comment on est comment on est on
est perçue mais respectivement par
violence oui mais quand on a un peu de
tempérament on est dans une ambiance que
vous connaissez bien ici à l'assemblée
les débats sont pas toujours feutrée
oui je l'assemblée nationale où c'est
vraiment votre canon non non c'est pas
s'est insurgé aussi je pensais quand on
est et on est souvent à l'assemblée dans
des moments de pression forte et là bas
on se cache pas on est tel que tel que
l'on est si on veut rentrer dans un jeu
de rôles ça ne tient pas longtemps on
peut le faire bien évidemment à certains
moments mais
non je trouve jury ce que veulent dire
les collègues proposent de passer à
toute l'actualité de la semaine on est
là dit on va parler d'europe avec une
avancée pour l'europe
mais sûr parler des travailleurs
détachés qu'on était en discussion cette
semaine à bruxelles les ministres
européens du travail se sont mis
d'accord pour améliorer la législation
européenne dans ce domaine explication
elsa en baccarat
il a fallu de longues de très longues
négociations pour parvenir à un
compromis les ministres du travail des
28 pays membres de l'union européenne
étaient réunis pour renégocier la
directive détachement
c'est un accord très important qui
bénéficiera à tous les pays membres
qu'ils accueillent des salariés détachés
ou qu'ils ont des tâches eux mêmes
cette directive date de 1996 elle
autorise les salariés européens à
travailler dans un autre pays que le
leur salaire minimum du pays d'accueil
mais charge et sociale du pays d'origine
de quoi encourager une forme de dumping
social accentuée par de très nombreux
abus en europe jusqu'au dernier moment
deux camps se sont affrontés le point
qui a fait longtemps débat c'est
l'instauration d'une responsabilité
solidaire entre les donneurs d'ordre et
les sous-traitants pour cette
responsabilité partagée le camp français
avec l'allemagne mais aussi la bulgarie
et la roumanie
parce que cette responsabilisation
généralisée et la seule façon efficace
de lutter contre des montages frauduleux
transnationaux en permettant que puisse
être remonter la chaîne des
responsabilités des sous traitants
vis-à-vis des donneurs d'ordre était
contre le royaume uni l'irlande et la
pologne la pologne qui a changé d'avis
au dernier moment l'option française a
donc été retenue puisqu'avec la
responsabilité partagée une liste
ouverte de document pourra être réclamé
en cas de détachement insurgés comme
avec cette victoire française le parti
socialiste va en faire son axe de
campagne pour les élections européennes
le front national avait fait l'un vers
son prenons également comme axe les
travailleurs détachés vous vous situez à
quel endroit vous dis qu'il ya une
avancée sur la restauration
responsabilités en solidarité mais on
n'est pas du tout sur le fond du sujet
c'est pas ça qui va changer l'alpha et
l'oméga du coût du travail le sujet pour
nous en france c'est le coût du travail
nous avons un coût du travail qui est
trop élevé et à partir de là il faut
trouver d'autres assiettes de
financement de la protection sociale et
là on fait un alignement en fait par le
site qui visant à favoriser le coût du
travail le plus élevé or il faut au
contraire harmonisées pour baisser notre
coût du travail et augmenter le salaire
net c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
toujours milité pour une assiette de
financement de la protection sociale qui
ne repose pas sur les salaires mais sur
une autre assiette beaucoup plus large
il ya aussi des vocations delà de la
fraude puisque certaines et certains
jeunes etc sur la solidarité et sur la
fraude ça va dans le bon sens mais ça ne
résout rien sur le fond rien parce que
sur le fond ce qui compte c'est de
baisser notre coût du travail qui est
trop élevé en france et qui nous retire
la compétitivité vous le recours à ces
salles avant puisque moi pourquoi un
recours à ces salariés il ya deux
raisons parfois parce que on ne trouve
pas dans c'est une des difficultés en
france nous avons des offres aujourd'hui
qu'ils ne trouvent mais preneur et donc
il faut bien aller chercher des salariés
ailleurs et aussi sur certaines périodes
des coûts du travail très élevé qui font
qu'il ya cette tentation pour maintenir
l'entreprise et pour que l'entreprise
continue à vivre de faire travailler ces
travailleurs étrangers donc une
responsable d'agencé mais on résout rien
sur le fond dossier à suivre à bruxelles
alors on passe à mardi pas de questions
d'actualité au parlement mais un débat
sur l'intervention française lancée en
centrafrique
l'opération fait plutôt consensus au
parlement mais les questions sont
nombreuses sur ce nouveau front ouvert
en afrique interrogations sur le coût de
l'opération sur sa durée à droite comme
à gauche on déplore aussi l'absence de
participation internationale extrait de
séance à l'assemblée je voudrais rendre
hommage indique olav au caire et antoine
le quinio l'o2 soldat tué hier en
centrafrique
la représentation nationale unie en
silence hommage aux deux militaires
français de 22 et 23 ans morts aux
combats près de bangui les deux premiers
morts de l'opération 100 garris
l'intervention en centrafrique fait
consensus sur les bancs de l'assemblée
cette unité mesdames messieurs des
députés nous là devant d'abord à nos
soldats mais à la tribune les questions
sont nombreuses à commencer par le coût
de l'engagement français le vote récent
d'une loi de programmation militaire
faible sans position sans ambition pose
avec acuité cette question aurons-nous
dans la durée les moyens d'une stratégie
où la france serait le seul gendarme
dans cette partie du monde le premier
ministre rappelle que paris agit sous
mandat de l'onu pas comme gendarme de
l'afrique mais et communistes et les
verts accusent mettant en cause l'action
de la france dans son ancienne colonie
les dictateurs ont été choisis et
maintenu au gré de nos intérêts entre
guillemets mais aussi pour protéger des
bases militaires françaises dans ce pays
considéré comme un porte-avions au
centre de l'afrique utilisé lors de
nombreuses interventions milite dans la
région n'ayons pas peur de le dire la
france a une responsabilité liée à
l'histoire coloniale dans la faillite de
l'état centrafricain interrogations
aussi sur le manque de participation
européenne seuls quelques pays ont
apporté leur soutien à la france autant
de questions pour l'instant sans réponse
si l'opération sans gary se prolonge au
delà de quatre mois le gouvernement
reviendra cette fois pour un débat avec
un vote christian jacob un certain
nombre de questions sur la raison de la
présence française en centrafrique mais
il faudrait que vous écoutiez le
président de la république qui a rendu
le jour même visite aux troupes à bangui
antoine et nicolas sont morts pour la
france
pour une noble et belle mission
ils ont donné leur vie pour en sauver
d'autres
car tel est le sens de votre présence
ici en centrafrique la france est à
nouveau en première ligne sur le
continent africain cette fois au milieu
d'une guerre civile y être déjà eu deux
morts pour vous l'opération doit se
poursuivre coûte que coûte vous la
soutenez à 100% oui ou non la france ne
pouvait pas ne pas aller à bangui pour
pour plusieurs raisons des intérêts
humanitaire est évident risque
génocidaire mais aussi et et disons le
clairement des intérêts géostratégiques
qui sont essentiels pour nous lorsque
vous prenez cette grande bande
sahélienne où vous partez de du mali et
pour en passant par le niger avec nos
sites d'extraction d'uranium et vous
redescendez sur la centrafrique on voit
bien que cette bande du sahel en train
de le descendre et là il y à des sites
économiques mais il y a aussi des
possibilités de refuge pour de la
criminalité des réseaux criminels
terroristes
et pour la grande criminalité et ça le
risque il et géostratégiques salon vous
entendu dans le reportage que nous avons
diffusé à l'instant on est seul oui mais
c'est à dire une vieille deux choses 1
nous devons y aller et nous soutenons
cette initiative
les regrets que j'ai exprimés c'est sur
la préparation comment la france est
aussi isolé j'ai bien compris ce qu'est
ce que c'est la faute de tout l'exécutif
que nous sommes les seuls à pouvoir
intervenir aussi oui ça c'est un autre
une autre chose à dire que peut y avoir
aussi un accompagnement financier
matériel il yad'autres d'autres
possibilités d'abord nous intervenons
dans le cadre du champ international
avec un mandat de l'onu souvenez-vous
moi je m'étais opposé très durement à
l'idée d'une intervention en syrie qui
était déraisonnable déraisonnable la
france y est lent seul sans mandat tout
cela n'avait aucun sens là nous sommes
dans un autre cadre il y a une
résolution 21-27 de l'onu qui nous
permet donc d'avoir cette action en
revanche que je regrette c'est qu'il n'y
ait pas eu peut-être suffisamment un
tour des capitales européennes qui
étaient faites pour trouver et des
moyens financiers et de la con agne mon
matériel normal qu'il n'y ait pas de
participation financière européenne pour
réclamer notamment un fonds européens
tout à fond les opérations ont
d'ailleurs présenté là une proposition
de résolution à l'initiative d'un de nos
collègues pierre lellouche qui était
fait sur la niche de l'ump à nice
parlementaires de l'ump pour demander la
création de ce fonds on souhaite et je
crois que ça va être le cas quel que ce
soit voilà ce soit évoqué dans le cadre
du prochain week-end et il faut là qu'il
y ait de responsabilité solidaire
effectivement la france a une
spécificité c'est qu'elle est la seule
avec le royaume-uni avoir une capacité
de projection de forces à l'extérieur
mais continue à avancer sur cette europe
de la défense d'amour christian jacob
est ce que françois hollande doit parler
aux français avant le 31 décembre pour
expliquer une des raisons de notre
présence sur place
je pense que les les raisons doivent
être davantage expliqué il ya un manque
de pédagogie c'est à dire qu'on a bien
vu les premiers sondages les français
n'ont pas compris pourquoi on allait là
bas et là nous avons une responsabilité
directe la décision d'envoyer des forces
c'est la décision personnelle du
président de la république c'est lui
s'expliquer le chef des armées il doit
l'expliquer et nous nous soutenons cette
opération donc moi j'ai pris ma part
d'explication en disant qu'il y a des
intérêts humanitaire mais pas seulement
il y à de vrais intérêts géostratégiques
qu'il faut assumer et assumer clairement
qu'on ne veut pas ce que se créent des
réseaux de terroristes et de criminalité
sur l'intégrisme islamiste dans cette
zone et y ait aussi des intérêts
économiques alors mardi toujours autre
événement l'hommage à nelson mandela
alors à paris en début de séance députés
et sénateurs ont observé une minute de
silence à la mémoire de la grande figure
de la lutte anti-apartheid françois
hollande était donc lui en afrique du
sud pour cet hommage planétaire près
d'une centaine de chefs d'état et de
gouvernement réunis dans le stade de
soweto et pour la france deux présidents
avec cette image qui a fait le tour des
réseaux sociaux françois hollande
nicolas sarkozy côte à côte dans la
tribune est-ce que c'était pas un peu
déjà la fiche de 2017
écoutez on en reparlera en 2010 700
jetons
c'était républicain que
françois hollande propose à nicolas
sarkozy de venir qui colle à sarkozy
elle accepte bon je crois que là on est
dans les principes et la quantité notre
public des images comme celles ci vous
aimeriez en voir plus souvent
ça change la nature des cheveux mais bon
voilà c'est républicain et ce qui s'en
vient nous devons dire qu'est ce qui
vous attend les coureurs comme ça dans
le stade et pour tout vous dire
j'ai d'autres sujets de préoccupation
sur la
jetons que c'est bien les républicains
qu'ils y soient tous les deux bref c'est
pas un événement majeur de la vie
politique française à avoir passé sur
d'autres sujets majeurs peut-être à
l'assemblée nationale voir parler de
l'écotaxe à l'assemblée comme au sénat
une mission d'information à l'assemblée
une commission denquête au sénat
l'écotaxe est au centre des
préoccupations des parlementaires
écoutez à ce propos le vice président de
la mission d'information à l'assemblée
le socialiste
l'argent de la taxe poids lourds
pourrait servir par exemple à améliorer
le réseau ferroviaire mais ces 800
millions de perdus pour l'état si on met
pas en place la taxe poids lourds ça
veut dire que des investissements
ferroviaires seront revus à la baisse
qui vaudra les remettre en cause et puis
si on revient sur la signature du
contrat avec est comme nous il ya une
pénalité de 800 millions huit cent plus
puissant ça fait déjà un milliard 6
beaucoup d'argent aux jeux vous l'ump a
décidé de ne pas siéger dans cette
mission d'information nous nous y
participons on ne prend pas de postes de
responsabilité dans cette dans cette
mission
on est dans une aberration ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui c'est la goutte d'eau
de trop c'est à dire que le trop-plein
fiscale
l'argumentation sur le financement des
infrastructures
bien sûr c'était ça le concept mais si
on va sur ce registre là on peut trouver
des économies ailleurs et vous avez ses
émissions dans est également au sénat
qui va devoir faire toute la lumière sur
cette société commune aussi si oui mais
là dessus des jeux des procédures
et toutes été validées y compris parle
par le conseil d'état donc nous donner
sur quelque chose avec une procédure qui
ne l'assumé pas vos responsabilités
c'est ça mais bon maintenant j'assume
pleinement si le jeu c'est nous ce que
nous disons aujourd'hui c'est que c'est
la goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le
vase l'économie à saturation de l'impôt
regardez ce qui se passe sur cette fin
d'année avec le collectif budgétaire 13
milliards d'euros de ressources qui
manque c'est à dire qu'il ya un moment
il ne s'agit pas de remettre de l'impôt
pour pour faire plus de rentrées
fiscales ça ne passe plus l'économie
asphyxiée c'est ça la réalité et c'est
pour ça que tous s'accordent sur cette
semelle sur six mois je pense qu' il y à
la nécessité de financer les grandes
infrastructures
mais on peut le faire avec des économies
ailleurs et il ya des sources d'économie
à paris x arrêtons de je pense que cet
impôt aujourd'hui n'est pas adaptée
compte tenu de l'augmentation précédente
d'impôts qu'il ya eu celle ci quand le
vase déborde eu des morts et des morts
et les français même support et pourtant
en 2009 il y avait quand même une
unanimité sur cette huile est simplement
changer ce qui a changé c'est qu'il 55
milliards d'impôts nouveaux en dix-huit
mois de créer par les socialistes et 20
milliards de dépenses publiques
nouvelles créées par les socialistes en
18 mois et que quand la coupe est pleine
a les plaids et c'est le cas c'est ce
qui se passe on vous avez été président
des jeunes agriculteurs en d'autres
temps vous seriez agriculteurs
aujourd'hui vous manifesterez également
à je pense que j'aurai manifesté contre
ce cette surcharge fiscale qui asphyxie
les entreprises le gouvernement des élus
bretons et des bonnets rouges en
bretagne vous dire ce que j'en ai fait
j'étais président du cndd il ya 20 ans
dire ce que j'aurais fait à 20 ans je
sais pas vous répondre à ça simplement
je me serais mobiliser contre cette
asphyxie de l'économie qui est
gravissime pour les agriculteurs pour
les pm pour les artisans pour les
professions libérales cas de la bretagne
assure bien sûr que vous revu la la
bretagne est un révélateur mais c'est
beaucoup plus large alors retour à la
vie politique l'ump n'a pas encore fait
toutes ces listes pour les prochaines
élections mais certaines investiture
provoque déjà quelques tensions au sein
du parti notamment celle de nadine
maurer morano annoncé dans le grand test
réactions vives de bernard accoyer et
contre attaque de l'intéressé écouter
ses propos recueillis par thibault le
floch je n'ai pas une question de
personnes tel ou tel homme ou telle ou
telle femme a ses chances mais il ne
faut pas que celui ci ou celle là vienne
se substituer à quelqu'un qui a déjà
prouvé son action là nous en voyons sans
arrêt des novices en france au parlement
européen c'est aussi des explications de
la perte d'influencé de la france au
niveau européen malheureusement bernard
acoyer s'est fait depuis plusieurs mois
une spécialité qui est de tirer contre
son camp et là je cours je dois dire
qu'il mérite un véritable carton rouge
en matière de comportement contre sa
famille politique
c'est quelqu'un qui quelque part s'est
égaré dans ses propos et je dirais
également qu' il mérite un carton gourou
j'en inélégance ont il est assez réputé
pour son côté macho je comprends que je
suis une femme mais que malheureusement
je suis pour lui sans doute peut-être
pas le profil qui lui convient à comment
vous réagissez à cette polémique bernard
accoyer accusé par nadine morano de
tirer contre son camp est ce qu'il ne
dit pas tout finalement ce que beaucoup
à l'ump pensent tout bas
période d'investiture bon c'est toujours
le cas dans ces périodes d'investiture
parce qu'il faut faire des choix qui
sont toujours des choix douloureux qui
sont toujours des choix entre des amis
de votre famille politique ce geste est
toujours compliqué il y en aura d'autres
lorsque mais c'est la nature des choses
quand vous avez un deux trois candidats
pour une tête de liste il faut bien
rendre un arbitrage et l arbitrage il
doit se faire sur le choix du meilleur
candidat et donc illégitime celui qui
est compétent qui connaît quelque chose
à faire c'est celui qui est capable de
gagner voilà parce que c'est le charmant
cette radio de gagner une élection quand
on est candidat et donc non mais quoi
très mal d'être classé non non non je ne
veux pas entrer là dedans je pense que
c'est parce que c'est pas parce qu'on on
a perdu une fois une élection dans sa
vie qu'on a une croix sur le dos à tout
jamais tout le monde n'a pas les mêmes
circonscriptions tout le monde n'est pas
dans les mêmes conditions donc ça peut
arriver mais ça n'en fait pas un critère
déterminant ni dans un sens ni dans
l'autre et de la même façon il faut
aussi reconnaître ceux qui travaillent
et ceux qui ont accompli leur mandat
avec beaucoup d'engagement et de qualité
savoir faire la part des choses et un
équilibre entre l'expérience on est avec
des personnalités condé forte notoriété
et on va arriver à trouver cet équilibre
on nous avons la commission nationale
d'investiture en janvier à chacun va
pousser sérieux et c'est normal et c'est
ça dans un parti politique
et puis on a aussi ce son là on verra
les listes ça c'est pour les élections
européennes il vous a pas échappé que
dans 100 jours nous serons aux élections
municipales jour pour jour alors quelles
sont les préoccupations des français
c'est le zoom de la semaine
et pour parler des préoccupations des
français nous accueillons bruno jeanbart
bonjour bonjour directeur des études
politiques d'opinionway l'institut de
sondage vous avez publié d'ailleurs
cette semaine un sondage sur quoi se
détermineront en fait les français dans
cette élection est la fiscalité arrive
en numéro 1 est ce que vous avez été
surpris de cet item ce qu'on appelle cet
item c'est à dire qu'il arrive en tout
premier des préoccupations alors oui non
oui parce que c'est quand même atypique
et c'est très rare que la fiscalité sont
un enjeu aussi fort dans une élection en
général c'est plutôt une thématique qui
compte mais qui est plutôt secondaire et
non parce que évidemment depuis
maintenant quelques mois ce sujet quand
même sur le devant de la scène sur
l'ensemble du territoire on a vu ce qui
s'était passé dans l'ouest du pays et
donc de ce point de vue là ça n'est
aussi que la conséquence de ces tensions
qui ont émergé sur la question de la
fiscalité en jacob jusque une réaction
est ce que l'ump entend ces
préoccupations comment il répond tél
mais moi je pense qu'on est sur un vrai
sujet clivant celui de la fiscalité
celui de la dépense publique et que l'on
peut tout à fait au regard des
collectivités faire la définir assez
facilement à partir de la dépense
publique et de la fiscalité les
collectivités de gauche et de droite
avec deux approches qui sont différentes
la même façon que sur le travail si on
le prend sur un plan national regarder
des dates comme 80 88 97 3 dates de
gauche vous avez la retraite à 60 ans en
81 vous avez ensuite en 81 ans 81,8 le
rmi et puis en 97 les 35 heures la cmu
trois fois on est dans une logique de
moins de travail plus d'assistanat plus
de dépenses à provins que c'est la
priorité c'est la fiscalité également
les autres c'est un sujet lié avec les
services parce que dans les
collectivités territoriales les gens
sont aussi très attentifs aux services
qu'on ne regarde pas tous sous l'angle
des impôts mais les écoles l'équipement
l'équipement culturel l'équipement
sportif tout cela il y sont aussi
attentifs donc il faut aussi balancé au
jojoba est-ce que vous avez l'impression
que les français sont entrés dans cette
campagne s'amassant jour n'ont pas
encore montré clairement quand on
regarde les indicateurs qu'on avait dans
cette enquête l'intérêt pour la campagne
est encore relativement faible un peu
plus d'un français sur deux indices de
mobilisation et augurent aussi très
faible on est aujourd'hui à 55
pourfendre des gens qui seraient prêts à
aller voter contre une participation
c'est peu mais on est loin on est à
quatre mois de l'élection donc c'est
logique mais donc clairement on n'est
pas dans la campagne et ça il faudra
près parce que votre campagne c'est
vraiment à partir de janvier et donc il
faut aussi prendre toutes les mesures
qui ont fait qu'ils sont intéressantes
aujourd'hui en termes de rapport de
force électoral dans les vivre avec
précaution parce que la campagne va
débuter l'année prochaine pourtant selon
votre sondage 42% des personnes
interrogées ont l'intention d'exprimer
une fois de plus leur vote sanction ce
dans ce scrutin est-ce que selon vous le
vote sanction va progresser pour ses
prochaines municipales il existera et du
contrat est-ce qu'il va progresser c'est
toujours difficile à dire par rapport à
d'autres scrutins on a vu dans les
scrutins dans l'ordre du quinquennat
précédent qu'il avait été fort je pense
qu'il sera aussi important dans cette
élection il ya des indices de ce point
de vue là assez contradictoire mais mais
on a pour l'instant quand même le
sentiment que oui il ya une part
importante je notais par exemple on a un
électeur de françois hollande au premier
tour de 2012 qui aujourd'hui nous dit
qu'il veut exprimer son mécontentement à
l'occasion de ces élections de vous
arranger tout ça ce qui enverra du repas
parce que c'est jean françois copé qui
avait dit ça y un peu plus d'un an
est-ce que vous aussi vous vous parier
aujourd'hui moi je suis tout à fait
confiant sur ces élections municipales
après c'est la politique c'est d'abord
l'école modiste crier victoire trop vite
donc regardons je pense qu'on en a bien
une vraie identification un vrai clivage
droite gauche par rapport à la dépense
publique et là il ya un angle qui tique
et je pense bien reçu par l'opinion
publique et qui pour nous nous favorise
pour les élections municipales ensuite
c'est lié aux équipes aux qualités ou
enfin ils ont prochaine que toujours
cette semaine par aida big bang
économique est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec lui sur le big bang économique une
révolution fiscale
légèrement plus à droite quand même on
sent que c'est les libéraux qui ont la
main cette fois chez les travaux que
nous avons fait nos groupes
parlementaires c'est ce que nous avons
réalisé comme travaux au groupe
parlementaire on est parti sur l'angle
économique avec plusieurs angles celui
du coût du travail du temps de travail
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes pour les 39 heures payées 39 pour
des vraies réformes de structure abrite
est pour vous la baisse du coût du
travail des charges patronales donc
c'est aussi dans cet esprit là que l'on
propose sur les la réforme des retraites
de passer d'un âge de départ légal à la
retraite à 65 ans plus tôt et certains
plutôt que tout à fait ce qui était
validée au sein du groupe en tout cas
delà de la même façon que nous sommes
allés aussi sur le financement de la
protection sociale par un autre une
assiette plus large qui peut être celle
de la de la tva mais sur les retraites
c'est aussi alignement public privé la
suppression des régimes spéciaux
lagrave lui aussi j'en déduis redevenant
le jeu se termine raccourcir notre
système d'indemnisation du chômage quand
on se compare à doper sans doute plus
élevée au départ beaucoup plus dégressif
ensuite est plus court dans son ensemble
donc toutes ces propositions là c'était
un an de travail de notre groupe
parlementaire des députés et qui est des
sénateurs et nous l'avons validées au
mois de septembre dernier jean bardin
mots que le tournoi est un petit peu
compter la droite est attendu autour
donc pas sur ce genre de proposition ce
qui est sûr c'est que on voit bien et
c'est assez classique avec la gauche au
pouvoir il ya une remontée des demandes
un peu libéral économiquement et d' un
desserrement de l'étau de la part de
l'état mais c'est pas un phénomène
nouveau on a vu même phénomène après
l'élection de françois mitterrand en 81
on a vu un peu de même phénomène aussi
après 97 donc je dirais qu'on est un peu
dans la même situation aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup vous des gens barre de nous
avoir éclairé sur ce sondage à cent
jours des élections municipales et on
passe à jeudi avec la question de
l'immigration qui ressurgit
l'ump a tenu une convention pour définir
la ligne du parti sur le sujet au
programme la réforme du droit d'asile le
droit du sol ou encore l'aide médicale
d'état aucun sujet n'a été éludé
regardez ce sujet de germes andrieu à
quelques mois des élections municipales
et surtout des élections européennes pas
question d'oublier le thème de
l'immigration au siège de l'ump jean
françois copé vise directement la
majorité et le front national l'ump
n'est pas dupe de l'alliance de fêtes de
l'alliance objective qui existe entre la
gauche et l'extrême droite sur ce sujet
de l'immigration j'ai appelé ça le fn ps
je persiste et signe réforme du droit
d'asile suppression de la mba ou
l'imitation du regroupement familial
l'opposition avance quarante et une
proposition pour contrer le front
national et remettre à plat la question
des flux migratoires nous disons
simplement aujourd'hui sur le droit du
sol qu'il ne faudrait pas le droit du
sol accordées aux enfants soit une prime
au séjour irrégulier car autant nous
assumons une immigration régulière sur
les critères choisis qui doit bien se
passer pour tout le monde naturellement
aussi pour les personnes que nous
accueillons autant ne voulons pas
d'immigration irrégulière ne voulons pas
donc que l'enfant de personnes
séjournant régulièrement en france est
automatiquement la nationalité française
alors il peut y avoir ici ou là
des voix divergentes mais la ligne
directrice des valeurs et des
propositions de l'ump sont celles qui
sont faites notamment aujourd'hui pour
le moment jean françois copé françois
fillon bruno le maire ou encore xavier
bertrand ne sont pas tous d'accord sur
ces propositions toutes doivent d'abord
être validée par un vote lors du conseil
national du 25 janvier avant d'être
inscrite dans le projet d'alternance de
l'ump alors il ya beaucoup de
propositions et certaines très radicale
la droite ne veut pas laisser ce thème
de l'immigration front national c'est un
thème sur lequel on peut pas s'enfermer
dans des slogans et dans de la démagogie
il faut prendre avec sérieux moi ce que
j'ai choisi de faire au sein de notre
groupe parlementaire nous avons mis en
place un groupe de travail sur six mois
qui est rythmée par ya cette convention
au parti mais on continue à avancer on
ressortira des propositions printemps
avec trois volets un volet qui est celui
de l'attractivité sociale il y un sujet
d'autres activités sociales c'est
l'accès à l'aide médicale d'état
c'est l'accès à la cmu c'est l'accès au
rsa
ou à d'autres minima sociaux tout ça
voilà il faut regarder si dans quelles
conditions nous l'avons nous avons
commencé à le faire par exemple pour le
minimum vieillesse ou on a obligé avoir
dix années de deux résidences et de
cotisations dont on va avancer des
propositions dans ce sens là l'aide
médicale d'état je pense qu'il faut la
ramener à diminuer mais c'est quoi votre
philosophie c'est quoi votre philosophie
sur l'immigration mais la philosophie
c'est que l'attractivité social ne doit
pas être un facteur d'immigration
on vient dans un pays non pas pour
bénéficier de minima sociaux et d'être
assisté de ne pas travailler on vient
parce qu'il ya une activité économique à
un moment on peut travailler et donc
l'attractivité social c'est un sujet de
fond à prendre ensuite un deuxième volet
qui sont nos fondamentaux de
l'immigration là c'est le droit d'asile
c'est le mariage bien sûr le droit
d'asile il n'est pas question ne le
remette en cause simplement on a 60 60
mille demandes cette année il y en aura
sans doute davantage l'année prochaine
85 ou 88% sont déboutés mais sur ces 90
% qui sont déboutés 90 % restent ne sont
pas raconte mais ça n'est pas normal
donc il faut avancer sur ce point avancé
sur le classement des pays sur le droit
d'asile très concrètes sur l'intégration
s'il jallet mais sur le droit d'asile je
continue d'un mot faire le choix sur les
ya des pays qui sont des républiques
démocratiques où il n'y a pas de sujet
de droit d'asile et donc il faut pas que
le droit d'asile se transforme en une
filière d'immigration clandestine
mariages la même chose accès à la
nationalité même chose l'accès à la
nationalité moi ça ne me choque pas que
ce soit un choix plutôt qu'un droit de
fait lorsqu'un enfant né de parents
étrangers qui plus est en situation
régulière qu'on lui pose la question
s'ils souhaitent accéder à la
nationalité française qu'on ne lui donne
pas de droits que c'est comme ça qu'il
faut travailler et puis derniers volets
le volet européen si vous présenter leur
habileté à une question très concrète le
premier ministre a reçu un rapport dans
sera jean sur l'intégration il propose
d'autoriser le voile à l'école
quel message qui est envoyé on est dans
une provocation de plus moi je n'ai pas
pour vous êtes une projection du projet
lui attendait j'ai vu les extraits les
dépêches sur ce rapport je n'ai pas eu
connaissance du rapport ce qui en
ressort dans la presse aujourd'hui on
est dans une opération de provocation
tout cela n'a les infections des rations
de provocation imaginer en france que
l'on va rendre la faim autorisée le
voile dans l'enseignement public face
est un non sens c'est une hérésie c'est
n'importe quoi que d'écrire ou de
proposer des choses comme professeur
d'entre eux qui
m'aimait contre les français attendent
et moi je suis choqué par cela l'école
c'est l'école de la république je suis
attaché à des valeurs républicaines on
peut faire le choix d'un enseignement
privé religieux mais on va dans une
école appropriée mais on n'utilise pas
l'école delà de la république pour faire
valoir t'es peut-être enfin sa fiche est
de telle ou telle manière attendait tout
ça n'est pas sérieux pourtant ce rapport
aussi on lit que la france doit assumer
sa dimension arabe aux orientales
valoriser l'art a balancé léman ça aussi
ça vous choque ou mais oui parce que
c'est dit sur un ton de provocation ce
qui est important c'est que les accepter
que des jeunes puissent avoir accès le
plus facilement possible à des langues
langue étrangère d'abord la maîtrise du
français c'est quand même ça la première
la langue de la république c'est le
français on maîtrise le français la
proposition ensuite bien évidemment il
est important que des jeunes puissent
avoir accès à des langues étrangères que
ce soit des langues européennes ou
d'autres langues et l'arabe ne me choque
pas à partir du moment où on est dans un
enseignement fait pas
ddd des enseignants de l'éducation
nationale et c'est bien surtout un
enfant qui a des origines d'un pays
étranger qu'ils puissent redécouvrir
cette culture et maîtriser la langue
tout ça est parfait mais ça se fait dans
un cadre d'éducation nationale et on
assume la construction européenne est
l'histoire de la france et on ne la
transforme pas au gré d'un rapport qui
cherche à faire de la provocation alors
autre sujet qui risque de provoquer
aussi quelques roues et qui nous
intéresse beaucoup parce que c'est notre
quotidien jeudi soir dans le cadre du
projet de loi sur les métropoles les
députés ont voté un amendement qui
remplace les pv de stationnement par un
forfait qui sera fixée notamment par la
ville c'est une révolution sa création
jusqu'au bout et
je suis pas sûr c'est bon
pour vous soutenez cette mesure vous et
moi je suis très réservé je suis très
réservé pour des raisons d qui le voit
bien l'intérêt qu'il peut y avoir
dans l'est dans les communes je suis
maire de ma ville de provins de pouvoir
monter à certains créent un effet plus
dissuasif en même temps l'iniquité sur
la sanction ça me choque toujours qui
rentrera directement dans la ville et
qui me sort
je suis maire je vois bien l'intérêt
qu'il peut y avoir mais je pense que on
est dans la sanch il faut
savoir lors la loi ne nous empêche pas
de rester sur le système tel qu'il est
là donc on va regarder voyez sur ce
genre de choses j'aurais préféré qu'on
met six mois ou un an d'expérimentation
je pense que ce serait sans doute était
plus astucieux et de voir comment les
choses les associations craignent déjà
une flambée et dans le même temps les
jeux pan des comptes charbon d'abord le
la meilleure des choses c'est de
respecter la loi si on voulait pas avoir
de pv vous commencer par respecter la
loi vous garer là où c'est autorisé
pendant le temps autorisé il n'y a pas
de problème donc c'est d'abord certes
être les pv savait difficile pour les
élections municipales aussi nous les
élections municipales se joue pas là
dessus fort heureusement mais moi je dis
aux automobilistes qui sont très beaux
chine là-dessus commencer par respecter
la loi
mais après voilà je pense qu'il aurait
mieux valu passer par la voie
d'expérimentation alors on va revenir
sur l'homme de la semaine il a marché
pendant huit mois à travers la france
pour aller à la rencontre des citoyens
jean lassalle a parcouru six mille
kilomètres le député des pyrénées
atlantiques est arrivé en fin de semaine
à paris cette dernière étape l amont
d'un gars étaient dans ses parcs
bientôt la fin du périple pour le député
des pyrénées-atlantiques jean lassalle
6000 kilomètres d'une marche entamée il
y a huit mois et là c'est le
périphérique parisien que jean lassalle
franchi derniers kilomètres dernière
rencontre avec les français et le député
ne passe pas inaperçu
je veux pas vous en tirez la nuit le
début de la démarche de jean lassalle
semble faire l'unanimité
on apprécie cette proximité avec un
homme politique qui pose des questions
carnet de notes en main le meilleur
moyen de résoudre blême c'est de
détruire un terrain et de débours de
comprendre ce que je recherche surtout
c'est un manque d'écouté très fort et on
nous reproche de ne pas traduire un site
dans la politique et dans les
orientations que dans la vraie vie et à
chaque rencontre le député recueille les
doléances parmi les sujets les plus
abordés par les français leurs
inquiétudes sur la dette et leur
désamour face l union européenne j'ai
ressenti
une absence de futurs de projets
qu'est ce qu'on va faire et avec qui on
va le faire est-ce qu'on est français
parce qu'on est européenne parce qu'on
est mondiale mondiaux on sait plus qui
allait de sa marche le député garde des
carnets de l'espoir comme il les appelle
il se donne jusqu'à fin février pour en
faire une synthèse et la proposer au
gouvernement et à l'assemblée nationale
alors c'est ce qui s'appelle être sur le
terrain comment vous jugez cette
démarche de jean lassalle c'est un
exploit un acte politique fort ou rien
de tout cela jean lassalle c'est d'abord
une personnalité atypique et sympathique
de l'assemblée mais bon au-delà de ça
vous savez lorsque les maires les
députés les conseillers généraux sont
dans l'exercice de leur mandat ils sont
en contact tous les jours leurs
concitoyens il ya différentes manières
de le faire il a choisi de manière
plutôt sympathique de faire sécession si
on aime bien là la marche et le sport
c'est sympathique mais au-delà de cela
la réalité c'est vos quotidiens moi
quand je suis dans ma mairie à provins
je passe ma vie à rencontrer des vrais
gens et sur les vrais sujets concrets de
l'équipement sportif qu'il faut mettre
en place de l'équipement culturel de
l'aménagement de la voirie c'est ça la
ligue 1 mais mais j'adore la marche et
je le fais moi je me concentre trop sur
les périodes de vacances questions
doivent aussi donc on a beaucoup parlé
cette semaine c'est nicolas sarkozy
c'est notre plus de l'hebdo
les chaînes parlementaires vous propose
de suivre cette semaine et la semaine
prochaine à documentaire sur nos
antennes qui s'appelle la droite at-elle
tué nicolas sarkozy simon barbares il
avait pour nous il vous racontera en
2012 c'est vrai qu'une partie de la
droite l'a suivi du bout des lèvres et
n'a pas joué le jeu la droite at-elle
tué nicolas sarkozy c'est la question
titre du documentaire diffusé sur public
sénat ce week-end les auteurs anna
cabana et jean charles deniau reviennent
sur les rapports conflictuels quand
retenu l'ancien président de la
république avec son propre camp durant
ces trente dernières années ses débuts à
la mairie de neuilly marquée par le
sceau de la trahison seront un prélude à
cette relation si particulière qu'il
entretiendra au sein de la droite
française une pique la place et charles
pasqua pendant qu'il est à l'hosto qu'il
a mal au dos et lui dit oui je
m'occupais de terre d'élection il se
fait élire maire à sa place en allant
faire la conquête de tous ces grands
bourgeois les uns après les autres
qu'ils retournent avec un talent
d'avocats et un charme extraordinaire
les relations de fascination répulsion
entre nicolas sarkozy et la droite
remonte cette époque-là passer l'image
d'un traître c'est celle d'un
révolutionnaire irrespectueux de la
doctrine de son propre parti qui
bouleversera son camp lors de son
quinquennat même s'il ya en france comme
on le sait aussi la droite de
gouvernement des traditions qui sont
assez cohérente il n'en reprenait aucune
et au fond il n'en respecter aucune donc
il a pulvérisé tout le corpus rhétorique
et idéologiques de droite de
gouvernement mais sans un fabricant non
plus parce qu'il n'y avait rien à la fin
de très cohérent nul révélation notable
toutefois dans ce documentaire illustré
par des images d'archivés et des
interviews des ténors de l'ump où la
langue de bois a toujours la vie dure on
dit même que certains mauvais coup du
camp balladur quand le camp chirac
viendrait de lui sur quoi je n'ai aucune
information après la droite française at
elle tué nicolas sarkozy les auteurs
terminent leurs propos par une deuxième
question la droite pourra-t-elle se
passer de nicolas sarkozy en 2017 c'est
peut-être celle ci la plus importante
est votre question je vais vous poser et
si nicolas sarkozy
de finalement n'avaient plus besoin de
l'ump en 2017
écoutez d'abord est ce que nicolas
sarkozy a prévu d et candidat en 2017 je
n'en sais rien et je pose que je pense
que le
ça n'est pas aujourd'hui la réponse que
les les français attendent viendra le
moment de cela bien évidemment pour le
moment nous avons perdu les élections
présidentielles les élections
législatives et au lendemain d'une
défaite il faut se reconstruire celles
et ceux sont les travaux que nous
faisons et c'est ce à quoi je
m'emploierai au sein de notre groupe
parlementaire sur les sujets économiques
sur le sujet d'immigration sur les
sujets sociaux de bâtir un corps de
doctrine la façon de manière à devenir à
la fois audible et crédible auprès des
français et puis viendra le moment est
bien de celui qui portera nos couleurs
et la
plus tard selon à finir alors pour finir
pour finir vous a demandé de choisir
donc deux images votre événement de
l'année 2013 et votre personnalité de
l'année donc votre événement vous avez
choisi le mariage pour tous alors
pourquoi je crois que c'était un des
rares moments de la vie politique où il
y a eu à la fois une telle mobilisation
dans l'opinion publique et au parlement
et j'ai dire que les les deux ont avancé
en corrélation jamais je pense un débat
parlementaire n'a été aussi suivis et où
il ya eu une vraie adéquation entre ce
qui se passait le débat d'opinion dans
la dans la rue et dans et dans
l'assemblée et c'est un texte sur lequel
je souhaite clairement que la droite
revienne est l'homme de l'année pour
vous c'est qui lucien neuwirth
du sénateur vous avez le vélodrome
dernier
d'abord anciens grands résistants qui
rejoint le général de gaulle à londres
ensuite grand parlementaire si le s'il
en est il a été plus de 20 ans député
pratiquement 20 ans sénateur qu'elle
travaille deux fois et il a légalisé la
contraception
féminine
la pilule et je pense que c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui à la fois son engagement
auprès de de gaulle et puis sur les
sujets de société très grande
personnalité sur son temps merci
beaucoup plus sur shannon et 28 de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires bonne semaine